quand un pays pleure ceux des fins les
sports peut parfois venir des cieux
c'est visiblement la conclusion faite
par le gouvernement brésilien pour
lancer officiellement sa campagne de
vaccination le pays a eu l'idée
d'injecter les premiers vaccins au pied
du christ rédempteur qui domine rio dé
janeiro
tout un symbole pour le plus grand pays
catholique au monde qui déplore plus de
230 mille morts du coït 19
en angleterre tous les endroits sont
bons pour se faire piquer là aussi un
petit clin d'oeil religieux puisque un
centre de vaccination a investi ces
dernières semaines la cathédrale
anglicane de salisbury dans le sud du
pays outre manche
il est aussi possible de se faire
vacciner lors des cinémas des mosquées
ou encore dans le stade de wembley à
londres
le black construit les villes muséum a
lui aussi ouvert ses portes pour
vacciner la population
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique en
californie le parc disneyland d'anaheim
a rouvert ses portes pour y installer
des tentes blanches sur son parking un
immense coup de pouce pour un des états
américains affichant les plus faible
taux de vaccination en france si vous
n'allez pas au vaccin il vient à vous
dans l'agglomération de reims
il est désormais possible de se faire
piquer près de chez soi dans un maxi bus
une initiative permettant aux personnes
les moins aptes à se déplacer ne se
protéger en jordanie
on vaccine aussi à bord d'un car mais
celui ci ne se déplace pas dans le nord
du pays un minibus blanc a été installée
pour accueillir des citoyens mais aussi
des réfugiés
dans le royaume de jordanie on ne fait
pas de distinction sociale et lorsqu'il
s'agit de santé
[Musique]